وقف مع هذه الصور لجنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بعد اقتحامهم بيت احد
الفلسطينيين في جنين يتناولون الارجيله
كما نشاهد في الصور ويتهكم على اوضاع
المعتقلين المحتجزين في البيت في اوضاع
صعبه كما نشاهد في هذا
الفيديو معنا من جنين مراسل الجزيره حسان
مسعود حسان ماذا عن جديد الوضع خص تبعنا
هذه الصور لهذا الفيديو لهؤلاء الجنود
داخل البيت وهم يتعاملون مع اصحاب هذا
البيت كما تابعنا في هذه الصور بصور الغرض
منها الاهانه كما يبينه هذا الفيديو
حسن تماما عبد القادر هي من بين الصور
التي بدات تظهر عقب انسحاب قوات الاحتلال
من مدينه ومخيم جنين بعد اجتياح دام ثلاثه
ايام كان خلال هذا الاجتياح ممارسات عديده
بعضها وثق وبعضها لم يوثق لكن هذا الفيديو
ربما يعتبر احد المشاهد التي توضح طبيعه
الممارسات والاسلوب الذي بات ينتهجه جيش
الاحتلال عند اقتحامات لمخيم الجنين
ومدينه الجنين بشكل اساسي ولمختلف انحاء
الضفه الغربيه هذا الفيديو كان قد تم
تسجيله خلال اجتياح قوات الاحتلال ل
منطقه مخيم جنين وتحديدا تم تسجيله في
منزل ال
الغول الذين يقع منزلهم بالقرب من مقبره
الشهداء مقبره مخيم جنين في ال بالقرب من
المخيم في محيط المدينه وا كانت قوات
الاحتلال قد اقتحمت المنزل وقامت باعتقال
عدد من الشبان
وقامت كذلك بتقييده بوضعهم الى جانبها
وقامت
باستخدام ما يوجد في هذا المنزل سواء كان
عبر ما ما شاهدتموه من استخدام ل النرجيله
على سبيل المثال والتهكم على الشبان
وا الظهور بمظهر الاهانه لسكان هذا المنزل
او حتى لاستخدام كافه ال ما ما يوجد في
داخل المنزل كافه احتياجات الحياه و
مستلزمات الحياه التي كانت موجوده في
المنزل تم تحويلها والاستيلاء عليها خلال
فتره الاجتياح وهذا جزء من ما قامت به
قوات الاحتلال خلال هذا الاجتياح في عدد
كبير من المنازل كان كنا قد رفضنا
واستمعنا الى شهادات لعدد من سكان مخيم
جنين ومن ابناء مدينه جنين الذين اكدوا ان
قوات الاحتلال قامت باقتحام المنزل منذ
بدايه الاقتحام وقالت لهم انها ستبقى في
المخيم على اقل اربعه ايام وانها ستقوم
باستخدام المنزل وقاموا
ب اختيار غرفه واحده لهم في داخل المنزل
طبعا للنساء والاطفال
وا سمحوا للاهالي لنساء والاطفال بالبقاء
في هذه الغرفه وحدها ولم يسمحوا لها لهم
ان يخرجوا منها الا باذن حتى وان كانوا
يريدون ان يذهبوا الى بيت الخلاء او الى
غيرها كانوا يحتاجون ان ياخذوا اذنا من
جيش الاحتلال للتحرك وقام جيش الاحتلال
افراد جيش الاحتلال بالاستيلاء على هذا
المنزل بالمبيت فيه بالبقاء في منازل
الفلسطينيين طيله الايام الثلاثه لهذا
الاجتياح وهذه ايضا من بين الممارسات
اللافته التي بدات تنتشر بشكل واضح وواسع
خلال الايام الاخيره خلال الاقتحامات
المستمره في كل ليله للضفه الغربيه وخلال
الاقتحامات 15 الماضيه لمدينه ومخيم جلين
قوات الاحتلال كانت عاده ما تستخدم
المنازل لنشر القناصه وتقوم بهذه
الممارسات لكن الاجتياح الواسعه هذا قام
جيش الاحتلال خلاله بممارسات عديده من
بينها ايضا القيام
باستخدام الطعام
باستهلاك ما هو موجود في داخل المنازل
التي قام باقتحامها وتمزيق صور الشهداء
فيها التخريب في هذه
المنازل ايضا البحث عن اي وسيله من
وسائل الترفيع حتى خلال بقائهم خلال هذه
المنازل واستخدام هذه الوسائل وكان هناك
عده شهادات حول ذلك من قبل الشبان من قبل
الاهالي الذين التقيناهم عقب انسحاب قوات
الاحتلال هذا يضاف الى ما كنا قد شاهدناه
ايضا عندما قامت قواه الاحتلال باقتحام
المساجد في مخيم الجنين وفي مدينه الجنين
في حي الجابريات او حتى في المخيم الرئيسي
في الشارع الرئيسي في ساحه المخيم عندما
قاموا باعتلاء المنبر
بالترتيل بالت قتيل العبريه بالغناء عبر
سماعات المسجد وعبر استخدام
ايضا الميكروفون الخاص بالمساجد او حتى
عبر وضع شارات ورموز على المنازل وعلى
المساجد وحتى داخل المنازل كان هناك بعض
ايضا الصور التي شاهدناها وتابعنا خلال
الايام الماضيه عندما قام جيش الاحتلال
ايضا بوضع سكاكين على سبيل المثال على صور
ووجوه الشهداء داخل المنازل قاموا بالدخول
الى منازل اهالي الشهداء وقاموا باستخدام
بتنفيذ مثل هذه الممارسات نعم من جنين
غسان حسان مسعود شكرا جزيلا لك